Joy Reid very upset by the Supreme
Court's decision to get rid of
affirmative action in college admissions
and joy Reid's upset because she says
with that affirmative action she never
would have gotten into Harvard
let me just be clear I got into Harvard
only because of affirmative action I
went to a school no one had ever heard
of in Denver Colorado in a small suburb
I didn't go to Exeter or Andover I
didn't have college test prep I just
happened to be really nerdy and smart
and have really good grades the good SAT
scores but someone came to Denver
Colorado to look for me a Harvard
recruiter flew to Denver and I met up
with her at the Village Inn Restaurant
and did a pre-interview to get to route
to pull me into Harvard I wasn't I was
pulled in and the and the school's like
affirmative I got into affirmative leads
and it was literally not saying we're
going to take an unqualified person and
put them in Harvard we're going to take
a very qualified person who we would
never know existed and put them in
Harvard that's how I got there that's
how katanji got there that's how Justice
Jackson I should say justice Jackson got
there I didn't know that Joy Reid had
gone to Harvard
and this explains that her
explanation of how she got into Harvard
explains why I didn't know from her
commentary that she was educated at
Harvard and that's underscored by the
fact that she doesn't even know what
affirmative action is
she says I didn't get into Harvard
because I was given an unfair Advantage
because I was unqualified but then I was
given an artificial boost and then I was
allowed in that's not no
that's not affirmative action yes it is
that is what affirmative action is
affirmative action is
you have two students
one is white one is black let's say they
have the same test scores the black
person gets in the white person doesn't
or more often is the case white person
has one test score a black person has a
lower test score the black person will
still get in such as the advantage it's
not just true of black and white it's
the white people will be punished
primarily but also the Asian students
will be punished and the black people be
given an advantage but also
to some degree Hispanics to a great
degree Native Americans though there
just aren't that many Native Americans
in America anymore
so
it's this weight of giving people who
are less qualified an advantage
she says no affirmative action just
means that Harvard discovered that
Denver exists you think Harvard
University didn't know that Denver
exists yeah oh wow ever since
affirmative action was passed into law
we unless some fellows of Harvard
College we've discovered there's a state
called Colorado did you know and now now
we're going to send emissaries out there
to find people what are you talking
about
what on Earth are you talking about
colleges have always recruited people
colleges have always accepted
applications from all over the country
if Joy Reid got into Harvard because she
had a perfect SAT score and she was
validatory in her class and she was
really seriously Highly Educated highly
intelligent qualified person
a lot of big ifs over here then she
didn't get in because of affirmative
action she got in based on her strength
and qualifications
if maybe she didn't have that perfect
SAT score
and I don't know I don't know what her
SAT score was if maybe she wasn't the
valedictorian of her class if maybe she
wasn't as qualified as other people
then she did get in because of
affirmative action and she might say
well it's good I damn well want to get
into Harvard and it's good for me to get
in for X Y and Z reason okay maybe she
can make somewhat convincing arguments
but the flip side of that is that
someone
who was more qualified did not get in
because she was given that Advantage you
can't have
an unfair Advantage for one person
without an unfair disadvantage for
another person
if you liked the sound of that you are
going to love the taste of magic spoon
even more with magic spoon you can say
goodbye to Bland sugary cereals and
experience breakfast like never before
packed with high quality ingredients and
flavors that you already know and love
like cocoa fruity frosted and peanut
butter which is very very tasty magic
spoon will take your breakfast game to
new heights my producer Ben Davies can't
stop talking about how much he loves
magic spoons peanut butter cereal
to which I say hey you jerk stop
stealing the peanut butter cereal from
the office and let me have it instead
but he loves it he really likes it so I
figure I'll throw the guy a bone he can
have the box of peanut butter I'll save
myself for the other magic spoon cereals
have zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and are only 140 calories per
serving they're also gluten-free grain
free and soy free experience the magic
of magic spoon cereals by visiting
magicspoon.com Knowles and get five
bucks off your order Magic spoon is so
confident in their product they back it
with a 100 happiness guarantee if you
don't like it for any reason they will
refund your money what are you waiting
for click the link below or head over to
magicspoon.com Knowles to grab a variety
pack try it today magicspoon.com for
five bucks off your order
is the GOP racist this is the charge
from the libs for the last uh ever for
forever and they're still keeping it up
jensaki making this claim on MSNBC
then Richard Nixon's Infamous southern
strategy during his campaign for
president in 1968 the Republican Party
made a concerted effort to reach white
Southerners who used to vote for
Democrats by playing to their fears of
African Americans and the civil rights
movement and it worked by pitting one
group of Americans against another the
GOP successfully managed to split off
Southern whites from the Democratic
party now decades later the right wing
is Reviving that same Playbook this time
with Muslim Americans and trans people
hear me out here the GOP is trying to
recruit Muslim Americans a community
that makes up less than two percent of
the US population against another tiny
marginalized group of Americans
transgender people
huh
oh hold on let me do where's my pen I
gotta write that down what a fresh
Insight GOP racist southern strategy or
their target good grief I mean if this
is if this is what gen saki is bringing
to her role at MSNBC they might as well
just play reruns of Rachel Maddow Rachel
Maddow actually it's much more
interesting than than these lesser
commentators they might as well play
reruns of I don't know Lawrence
O'Donnell or Chris Hayes or Chris
Matthews or it's all the same nonsense
you could go back to an episode of MSNBC
from 2006 they'd be saying the exact
same nonsense that jensaki is saying
here
the GOP they're splitting off they're
doing it with it the GOP doesn't need to
split Muslims off of the LGBT community
okay Muslims don't need Republican
politicians to do that Muslims it turns
out have their own beliefs Muslim
they're real people they have intellect
they have will they have a vision of the
world that is not your vision
jensaki and the Liberals
and much as you might like to dominate
their vision and suppress their vision
and substitute out their understanding
their 14 year 1400 year old
understanding of human nature in the
world for your much newer vintage of
liberalism
you don't get to do that that's probably
not going to happen
and one aspect of Islam that Islam
shares with Judaism and Christianity and
many varieties of virtuous paganism is a
an opprobrium for
sexual eccentricity and deviancy
and one thing that Islam shares
with Judaism and Christianity and
even virtuous paganism is an
understanding of human nature such that
uh
your soul is not in radical opposition
to your body at the level of sex and
gender
you don't need the GOP to do that
people have their own
their own views
think about the Liberals can't
understand this the the Liberals much as
they malign colonialism
the Liberals have a much more intensely
Colonial flattening
universalizing point of view than pretty
much anyone else in the world including
Christians
liberalism in in many ways it's not
exactly a Christian heresy but it is a
perverted offshoot of Christianity it's
why liberalism arises in the Christian
West but it's a it's a perversion and in
the inversion of Christianity in all
sorts of ways and it makes an a God out
of man rather than having man recognize
God as his one true God and and it
exalts the will of man above all else as
opposed to Christianity which says that
man needs to bring his own will into
Accord with right reason and reality and
the will of God
but it is
kind of a weird little offshoot of
Christianity and Christianity is a
universalizing religion right
Christianity uh had the the oldest
flavor of Christianity is called the
Catholic Church Catholic means Universal
Christianity makes claims for the whole
world but it's not a it's not a
globalism it's not a flattening like it
recognizes
principles such as subsidiarity it
recognizes the legitimacy of civil
Authority
it respects custom and tradition
it doesn't try to flatten everything
there are all sorts of Rights in
Christianity there are all sorts of uh
local flavors
while at the same time there being an
insistence on one church with one Vicar
of Christ and one holy sacrifice in Mass
so
and one God obviously uh
liberalism just takes all that
particular isn't it takes all that
respect for local Authority respect for
tradition respect for the the
civil Authority it's just liberalism
just rips all of that out and says no
everybody's got to be exactly the same
not even down to this nation has to be
indistinguishable from this nation not
even down to this race has to be
indistinguishable from this race down to
this sex has to be indistinguishable
from the sex down to everything it just
flattens
it flattens it all much much more
Colonial than anything the Christians
have ever done boy what a great clip
that was huh make sure that you
subscribe ring that Bell here at the
Michael Knowles YouTube channel we'll
see you next time